mein name ist macht mal statt ich bin im
abwehrzentrum wir waren führend daran
beteiligt dem die korona einsätze die
wir durchgeführt haben anders als zu
planen und auch durchzuführen
dieser rückholung der österreicher von
frankreich dem sie zuvor im kino auf die
ordnung das eigentlich da der erste
einsatz von uns im abwehrzentrum hpc
bereich über wir in österreich vom
militär auch damit betraut war
und das sind eben noch viele weitere
gefolgt unter anderem haben wir eben
gemeinden das sind verziert und
kindergarten desinfiziert schulen das
sind verziert
ich glaube dass das bundesheer von
hierarchischen strukturen 1-satzführung
sehr stark erleichtert weil eben weniger
menschen die entscheidungen treffen und
entscheidungen wenn sie gewollt werden
auch sehr stark getroffen werden können
in meiner abteilung service sind die
experten themen aus und chemikern
biologen
näher und physikern für die
einsatzplanung kommen irgendwo offiziere
von der akademie zum einsatz gemeinsam
mit uns als eben hintergrund für dieses
spezialwissen
und andererseits eben auch dass die
durchführende erinnert das heißt täglich
allerdings gerade erst mal gut
aufbietung für dort dienen und zutaten
in dem lied
[Musik]
der größte es hat nur eben diese post
verteilerzentren dort dieses eben zu
einer hohen infektion der belegschaft
gekommen sind dann eben dafür zuständig
gewesen desinfektionsmaßnahmen vor ort
zu treffen innerhalb kürzester zeit von
allen möglichen paketwagen die wir eben
wie spezifiziert haben und andere
oberflächen wo heben und muss kontakt
voran das man zusätzlich noch 100 m 1
die waren eben dann dafür dauert sie im
bus verteilerzentrum dem laufenden
betriebs sicherstellung daneben die
belegschaft ausgefallen ist die
ursprüngliche
wir haben ist das fachwissen zusätzlich
aber auch diese melodie wird zur
verfügung stellen wird eben sehr sehr
viele soldaten stellen können und
innerhalb kürzester zeit ist eben auch
abschließen können
weiter lesen hier aufgabe es ist der
spur
das ist zudem die geschafft
logistische abwicklung dazu
nachdem ich mein studium abgeschlossen
haben chemische ökologie wasser
naturwissenschaftliches studium
geldsystem wissenschaften ist für mich
sicher die möglichkeit beim bundesheer
gegeben diese theoretischen hintergrund
gut zu setzen dass praktisch und also
das wirst du viele einsätze haben wir ja
davon wisse niemand ausgenommen
damit hat niemand gerechnet